Get the jab or get a new job. That's the
message from the government in Zimbabwe.
It's introducing a vaccination mandate for all of
its nearly 300,000 public sector workers. The idea
is to force those reluctant to get the
jab to finally roll up their sleeves.
Across Africa, there are still not enough people
getting vaccinated. Only about five percent of the
African population has so far been double jabbed.
That's compared to around 55 percent in Asia,
75 percent in Europe and 65
percent in South America.
A lack of vaccine is slowing the rollout across
Africa. But vaccine hesitancy is also posing a
growing challenge. Other African countries are
also considering making vaccination mandatory
for their public sector workers.
Are mandates like this the best way
to stamp out vaccine hesitancy? Privilege
Musvanhiri sent this report from Harare.
Garikai Mahlengwe is a teacher at a public
school in the capital Harare. He like many
other civil servants was vaccinated, but
only out of the fear of losing his job.
Garikai considers mandatory
vaccination for public workers
as discriminatory and a violation
of the freedom of choice.
"I feel we have been robbed of our rights
by the pandemic. This mandatory vaccination,
if it was mandatory to everyone, should
not have selected civil servants.
It seems as if civil servants are the
only human beings here and are the
only spearheaders of COVID
19, which is totally wrong."
Despite the call for public workers
to be vaccinated, the vaccination rate
has not gone up as expected.
There are hardly long queues at
vaccination centers if compared to a few months
back when the country was hit by the third wave.
While vaccines maybe readily available at
vaccination centers like this one. It is
the citizens’ response that is a bit low. It is
a trickle against what health authorities may be
anticipating. Perhaps because of the
conspiracy theories surrounding vaccines.
Zimbabwe is targeting vaccinating 60+ per
cent of its population, hoping to get close
to herd immunity. That accounts for 10
million out of its 15 million citizens.
The government says mandatory
vaccination means just that.
Some individual rights have to be restricted.
The government is saying you need to be vaccinated
to protect yourself and those that you serve.
Public servants are always working in public
spaces and interacting with the public. We need to
make sure that all public servants are vaccinated.
Worker unions have challenged mandatory
vaccination in courts but are encouraging
the government to provide vaccines to
all citizens willing to take up the jabs.
"It is illogical to force an employee
to get vaccinated at the same time
allow the same employee to interact and
mingle with a person who is not vaccinated."
For Garikai Mahlengwe, a vaccination
card is now the passport to work.
At least he is guaranteed a salary.
However, his case is not unique - many
countries across the world are now moving
towards COVID passports to access services.